after some confusion businesses are
slowly adjusting to the newly owned
the country's central bank says the
redenomination of sierra leone's
currency has been necessary so the magic
of redenomination is that
when you take those zeros away people
start thinking that they are poorer than
they actually are
and as a result of that
they will bargain more
when they go to buy goods and services
that should put a lead on prices a
little bit
some economies say the idea can only
work if government doesn't return to the
policies that led to the collapse in the
value of the money in the first place
the central bank says redenominating the
lyon will significantly reduce the
amount of cash people and businesses
carry around and the risks that go with
that but critics say removing three
zeros from the currency won't show up
its value
critics say previous monetary policy in
sierra leone hit the realities of the
economy by adding zeros to the currency
as a result the leon lost its value and
inflation worsened
the governor of the central bank says
the decision was tough to make given the
cost of printing new nodes and taking
the old ones out of circulation i would
not have done this at this time
but the cost to the economy the costing
reserves to the central bank
as we kept
month on a monthly basis putting out
dollars
to give to people who were hoarding
lyons to bring it into the system so
that the economy can keep going
doing that for a foreseeable future we
would have
wasted our entire reserves
some banks and business people say the
public response and acceptance of the
new currency has been encouraging
this no one make it more easy for us
because you can have 50 million
you can go with the 50 million without
afraid of tips to follow you because you
can even put it in your bag but for the
whole money you can feel the whole bag
and also you can put some in plastic so
that will give you a lot of gigs to the
tips around
in 2020 the central bank spent 68
million dollars shoring up the lyon now
it isn't saying how much the initiative
will cost but it will be hoping it will
rally the currency and the economy ahmed
idris al jazeera free town sir leo